[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Jim Jackson NBA on TNT Clippers analyst
Fox college basketball analyst one of
our favorites Jim Jackson joining us
from Madison Wisconsin
how's them around Jim how you feeling
I got the best job in the world man I'm
still undefeated since I retired I like
it I'm good all right yeah
um I was wondering you had a foot injury
when you were at Ohio State I I think
maybe a stress fracture and and watching
LeBron's injury
I think he first said that he stepped on
somebody's shoe or foot and then I
thought maybe it's a high ankle sprain
the way he landed to me looked different
and and more serious than a than you you
land on somebody's foot what did you see
in that situation
well I mean it goes back because a lot
of times with those injuries then as you
know it's a lingering effect of
something else
so that put that been bothering him for
a little while from my understanding
yeah so when you have a non-contact
injury like that again it's a result of
wear and tear something over time so
that was just like the needle in the
haystack right there one that kind of
took it over the top so when he planted
it and I saw it I was like oh man and I
started to hear more about the injury
itself because for you think about it at
this point in LeBron's career he's on
the back end
less dazed and more getting to the plow
is very important for him to be out
and talking about two weeks maybe three
has to be something really serious
because they had a chance to kind of
inch up and if nothing else get into
playing game and go from there
but I think the injury is more serious
than probably what they let on
because if it's two to three weeks to
just to be reevaluated it's probably
some swelling in there it looked like it
may be and I'm not a doctor but it looks
like it may have been under the arch of
his foot kind of like where plantar
fasciitis is at all of those soft tissue
injuries right there I think all got
affected on on that on that play and
then I got to wonder if in three weeks
he can come back do you even want him to
come back you know let's try to get the
play-in game or do we shut him down for
the rest of the season no matter what
well it depends on where the Lakers are
at too at that particular point because
A.D you know not playing back to back
game still hurts the Lakers now they
were able to split that series Memphis
and OKC and win that game in OKC and
give themselves a good chance to
continue to to kind of push up the
ladder a little bit but a lot has to do
with that I mean I like the moves that
they made in regards to the Acquisitions
does that get them a championship this
year I don't think so from a roster
perspective can they be competitive in a
one-game scenario in the play-in of
course LeBron is healthy A.D is healthy
and you got Vanderbilt playing a kind of
Defense he plays I mean an elite bz they
can be very competitive now in the seven
game series no home court advantage
that's a different story the most
threatening team in the west is who
the most threatening team in the west I
mean at the one on top of the
leaderboard which is Denver
that nobody talks about
because still The Narrative is around
Memphis if the Clippers get healthy and
whole in regards to you know the
Acquisitions and them playing together
um but yet Denver has been the most
consistent team they don't get a lot of
the credit because of their past
failures in the playoffs so it's weird
to say who could be the most dangerous
when that they're the best team in the
league in regards to the Western
Conference do you think they're the most
dangerous like they can be the best team
but playoff time the most dangerous team
in the west is
yeah you know why they got they're gonna
have home court advantage all the way
around okay they got the guy the Jokers
that can change the total complexity of
the game and you have some X factors
like Porter Jr that if he comes to play
that can be really serious now I mean do
we know how good the Mavericks will be
once Kyrie and they won last night Kyrie
and Luca of course because those two
again late game situations calorie leads
to four chord and scoring they could be
a team that from a match-up perspective
could be very difficult to have to
contend with especially if you are a
lower seated team
the team that is more for real for the
lack of a better description the Kings
the Grizzlies
oh that's a good one um Grizzly because
they have a little bit more experience
in the playoffs in regards to where
they've been
um the makeup of the team but now you
know but they're still young in some
aspects of it though Dan and that's the
part that kind of bothers me a little
bit
is that this year they came in with the
expectations because of what happened
last year which is great but if you look
at their team too they're still pretty
young in key position
um I love Desmond Bain
um Jaren Jackson to me is the key in
regards to being healthy in the playoffs
I love the way Taylor Jenkins kind of
manipulates the lineups and gets the
most out of his guys but I gotta get in
my head I mean my credit to Mike Brown
this there to me is the perfect Mike
Brown team you say why well when he was
with Cleveland he kind of had LeBron and
LeBron kind of ran things that the
Lakers it wasn't really it was still
kind of
everybody else's this is his team a
young team that is brought in and kind
of filtered out streamlined the
um roster so he didn't have a lot of
overlapping positions Darren Fox is on
point on pace so bonus is like probably
one of the best acquisitions
I really love the direction in which
Sacrament is going I really love how
they responded to Mike Brown even though
he's probably been criticized in other
scenarios about his offensive kind of
tapes and stuff
we're talking to Jim Jackson he's a busy
man NBA on TNT Clippers analyst you
called uh you got to Purdue at Wisconsin
or you had that last night and then last
night yeah Lakers are you sold on uh the
big man with Purdue
in college definitely well no you know
in college yeah okay but are you sold on
him I'll tell you why okay
five years in in regards to his
experience in playing
if you look at the preseason
All-American team there were four post
players traditional post players and one
guard Marcus Sasser so you had Oscar
Sheboygan Drew Timmy you had
um it was Zach Edie and Trace Jackson
Davis why because in college a
traditional post player is going to get
multiple touches all the time all the
time in the league that's not gonna
happen so post players can still be post
players and be dominant and why that is
effective is because now you got a
double team
so you have a lot of shooting available
around the court and Zach idiom will
tell you that watching him progress the
last few years the thing that gets me
and you can see how good he really is
one is competent you know you play well
Dan you've been around enough to know
guys start to get successful mentally
they know they can play his footwork his
touch around the rim his acceptance of
double teams and how to beat him and his
awareness Court aware all these things
you can watch and see that he's grown
accustomed to and comfortable with
that's why I like where he's at now to
me the the keyword Purdue is their
backcourt
because Fletcher lawyer and also Braden
Smith are two young freshmen who are a
little bit smaller at the guard position
that if they're not playing well this is
a different Purdue team
we were talking about scoring the uh
Antoine Davis trying to beat Pete
maravich's all-time scoring record uh
fell three points shy and we were
talking about different scoring outputs
are we going to see somebody you know
get to 80 points again like Kobe what's
the most point somebody scored on you
your team in a game that you were in
the trail Sprewell golden state scored
50 plus it might have been close to 55.
okay that and that was a year they were
transitioning
from
um they were renovating the arena in
Oakland and played in San Jose see I
tell you I still remember because the
trail went off on it
um at that point but you know getting 50
at that time 40 had meant something yeah
not doesn't not does it doesn't mean it
now but it's
the relevancy in which it's taken place
um what I mean the the amount of times
that it's taking place now kind of does
take away from it being more of a
special moment because of the rule
changes in guys doing it right now it's
like oh somebody got 50. whereas before
it's like oh somebody got 50. totally
different
I was uh watching how golden state was
playing defense on Russell Westbrook
and yeah Draymond Green is
way deep in the paint Rush is at the top
of the he could walk over dribble two
times and shoot a free throw
yep
yeah how's this happen
mental how does Ben Simmons know and not
want to shoot but do you think Russia is
mental because he wants to shoot no no
it's mental I'll tell you why because
then
this game is so delicate on the mental
side
okay that you would go from a Ben
Simmons who could score the basketball
who would never want to shoot the ball
he can go through a game and not even
look at The Rim a Russell Westbrook who
was known full speed to come down he'll
pull up for a jump shot 15 feet remember
you get to the left side use the glass
off your backboard you know he was
shooting three not that he was the most
efficient but without hesitation the
mental aspect of not being as successful
over and over and you say well I'm not
listening to the outside noise it's
impossible it's impossible because you
hear it no matter what and you play that
into your mind and you say well it
doesn't affect me well you say that but
the actions and what we see on the court
a lot of times reflect something totally
different and when you're that wide open
on multiple occasions and you don't even
look at the rim
it's mental
and that's why I say the the mentally
tough players are the ones that kind of
break through when things sometimes
don't go right which will happen when
you play this game long enough
but it it always felt like Russ should
stop shooting he kept shooting and he's
not a good shooter now draymond's
basically saying you can shoot a free
throw
go ahead I could he was embarrassing
Russell Westbrook with that
I know but here's the thing okay he's he
may not be a great three-point shooter
but he was a really good mid-range
shooter so why not take two dribbles and
pull up for 15. that tells you the
mental psyche in which where he's at in
his head because you're right
okay Draymond was like imploring him to
shoot the ball yeah okay no maybe I
won't take this three-pointer but I'll
come in a little bit closer 17 16 15
feet and make you pay for backing up but
Jimmy didn't do that I know that's
what's amazing but that but see but
that's the mental part of it Dan and no
matter how long he's played this game
and successful as he has been
father
strong-minded player one of the
strongest minded players that we've seen
play this game okay
allows that part of it that part of not
being successful to affect his whole
game that part of it affects everything
he does because you know why he ends up
getting himself in a little bit more
trouble trying to get closer to the rim
instead of shooting creating plays he's
turning the ball over making some
probably not the smartest decisions at
the end of the game because you know why
he won't shoot
who's going to get to 80 points
well Devin Booker could definitely get
there
um Giannis can get there because he gets
to the free throw line even though he
may not be the most skilled player like
he said
um we've seen
um Donovan Mitchell
get close of course Damien I mean if
clay gets hot we've seen it
what he can do from the three-point line
it's it's it's amazing too that
the way the wait I'm gonna take it back
if you want to play defense in this
league which is tough Dan and you want
to kind of carve out your Niche it's
hard
because you really can't play the way
you want to play because you're
penalized for being a really good
defensive player that kind of uses his
strength and size and length to be
really good and I get why the NBA NFL
baseball want more offense we want more
excitement I get it but then you lose
the essence of the challenge especially
in the NBA of the guy saying you know
what I want to take pride in shutting
somebody down give me a chance to do it
it's like a cornerback on a receiver
give me a chance to utilize my skill set
to be able to go one-on-one but if
everything is skewed towards an
offensive player what do I do
I might as well not play any defense and
and JJ Reddick has talked about this
that you know he's tired of hearing the
get off my lawn guys about the
physicality of the the way the game used
to be played but the reality of it is
the greatest player who ever played the
game
got roughed up and that's where the
Pistons created the Jordan rules and
Mike decided to get stronger that if you
look at it what was a hard foul a
playoff foul now you get thrown out of a
game so JJ has to understand while it
might not be you know
Greco-Roman wrestling back in the day I
could put my hand on you I could do an
arm bar on you and we didn't you know we
looked at it and like that's just a
heart they were called hard fouls now
yeah for a reason now it's the intent
what's the intent that's a technical so
when he says oh you know I don't want to
hear about the physicality it was there
can't deny that you don't have the
physicality you're not able to be
physical in today's NBA
no and I think JJ was trying to refer to
off the ball before a player gets it
like he I think he used step for an
example like off the ball the amount of
holding that takes place that's one
thing coming to the Lane and getting
hitting across the face with an elbow is
something totally different when you're
attempting a shot of trying to get
inside the lane going across the lane to
set a screen on a post player and
they're taught to put the elbow right in
your throat on your chest yeah it's a
little bit different than off the ball
and
then the the reason why I don't I try to
stay away from this is my argument about
errors
every air is totally different you it's
hard to compare the young men and women
that are playing the game today it's
hard for me to be upset with them
because all they know is what what's in
front of them all they can understand is
the game that they've been playing they
didn't grow up in the park they didn't
grow up playing in like you know raggedy
gyms they didn't play in backyards a lot
of them
so this is how this is how they see the
game and of course this is how they're
going to play when I grew up it was
Ally's it was it was the parks it was
backyards it was raggedy gems but that's
what I knew
I knew
how and my game reflected the era so you
can go from the 50s to the 60s to the
70s to the 80s to the 90s all of those
eras and the players the way they play
reflects the era in which they grew up
in so that's why when you go back and
forth you start trying to compare it's
impossible and I'll give you in a prime
example they said Well Steph couldn't
play in the 80s or 90s I said why they
said because he's too small I said well
Isaiah did Michael Adams did D Brown did
uh Mugsy Bogues play Spud Webb play I
said the difference is they grew up
playing the game a different way so you
can't transfer a step
said today and take it back to 85 86
because he wouldn't be playing the game
that way and vice versa you couldn't
take a Shaquille O'Neal Alonzo warning
and put him in 2023 and expect them to
be a dominant post player
that's where the argument kind of loses
a lot of its steam is because you can't
it's not trans it's not easily
transferable like that yeah it would be
interesting if you had one of those body
switching movies and Steph went back to
the 70s he's like hey Ralph he's got his
hands on me hey they knocked me to the
ground hey that's a that's a flagrant
foul oh you don't know what a flag no a
flagrant Fountain that's a hard found
stuff yeah but the coaches back then
would put somebody in the game and take
two to three hard fouls just because
absolutely just because and bring them
back out so you did your job like Rick
Mahorn or Charles Oakley wouldn't have
roles in today's NBA
you know what they'll be more like
Draymond
playmate
have to do those little things like that
seriously in today's game they can still
be physical from the perspective of that
but they would have to add a skill set
more so
for highly intelligent players though
okay they just didn't have the ball in
their hands like Draymond does yeah but
in order to you know in order to really
excel in this league you have to have
some kind of skill set in order that
benefits the team outside of you know
rebounding the basketball
always great to talk to you
man all right Zanesville Janesville Ohio
yeah
have you been to Zanesville Ohio
yeah how about this Dan
my senior year in high school Regional
semifinals in Columbus you played
Zanesville High School right and
well you know what happened you torched
him yeah we won did you see the statue
of me in Zanesville because
no they no they took it down for other
reasons oh they did well they are they
are taking down statues so yeah
[Laughter]
thank you Jim safe travels anytime
thanks brother all right that's Jim
Jackson